Film Courage: The opening pages of
a screenplay, important or cliché?
Jim Agnew, Screenwriter: Well clichés work for
a reason but if you do it well then it works.
What do you mean? What's the context of the
opening? Film Courage: How important are they?
Are people really tossing something in a pile
in a slush pile based on? Jim: Yeah they do but
it's if you can grab you have it has to play
professional, it has to read professional and
it also has to have something happening in the
beginning. It can't be just exposition people,
sitting around talking yeah it is and I’ve even
seen…here's another thing people don't know is
that producers will look at what the genre is and
see the page count at the end and it's if you've
written a script that's 150 pages they're this
person doesn't know what they're doing because
no one should write a script over 115 pages unless
you're Quentin Tarantino or Paul Thomas Anderson
and if it's a horror movie it's 140 pages are
going to be what that… is going on? Because
how many pages they're all I mean if you look
at most professional scripts they're always
studio scripts or anything they're 105 to
112 pages clockwork horror movies a little
bit less they're 98 to 104 but so they see so many
scripts and they know they can and you've got to
keep in mind your time you're competing for their
time against professional scripts they're getting
so it's got to be really awesome and it's got
to be bombastic in the beginning not not you're
blowing stuff up but you have to grab them
somehow do something somehow that really shows
oh wow I haven't seen that before wow that's
interesting have somebody have adrenaline needles
jammed in their heart on the first first
line wakes up where am I you do something
and that doesn't necessarily have to be how
the story starts but you have to figure out
a way to make it work and have the beginning
be something that's really really interesting
how much time do you spend on the first page of
a screenplay not much maybe 10 minutes maybe five
it just depends on the on the flow but a lot of
times when I first start something I'll just be
this and I kind of know because I've thought
about the beats of what I want to happen and
then I'll go back and rework it so it's I'm more
concerned not necessarily with all the dialogue
line for line but more what the scene is saying
what's the beginning middle and end of the scene
and what's trying to get across and then go
back and finesse all that stuff and two now I
do a new system now where I don't write any
description while I'm writing I'll just say
describe office and then go back and do that
at the end because it doesn't have anything to
do really with the story it slows you down yeah
yeah would paneling file yeah exactly and go back
and do all that one time at the end interesting so
you put in a little space holder yeah explain city
explain the car describe here now if it's really
important the story maybe I'll put it in but
if it's just if the spy movie it's and you
got to describe Paris as the sunrise comes up
I'll do that later just put established
pairs they just keep going because that's not
that's easy to do how do you write a screenplay
in two weeks I think a bigger question how do
you write screenplay in two days because
I've done that it's actually the time
writing is differs but it's how much have you
thought about it because there's times I think
I said earlier I'll think about something for two
three weeks before I even touch the keyboard about
the story and run a lot of it in my head and if I
get a big chunk of it's I could just write 20-30
pages in a day but I've thought about it it's not
just I'm looking at the blank page I'm not one of
those people stares at the computer I'll go for
walks I'll get coffee do whatever ride a bike
that's where I get all my ideas and for some
reason driving but it's you almost get in this
zone of thinking about things and sometimes when
I'm stuck I'll go for a walk I can come back and
write five or six scenes because I just saw it on
my head so yeah that's that's the process I mean
there's one screenplay I wrote in two two days
because I forgot when I was supposed to deliver it
and this is when I was first writing and then
it became it was supposed to be a half million
dollar little action movie that became a 10
million dollar film and I wrote in two days so
but there were a lot of parameters set on that
job it had to be one location don't want to change
wardrobe the actor can't talk too much because
he's an MMA fighter there are all these things and
I just was what I kept putting it off because I
really didn't want to do it I got paid and I was I
wrote in a weekend and then it became a 10 million
dollar film they didn't really use the script
it kept changing and changing but it so it you
never know strange things happen in this business
what's an example of lingering too long on a film
project that's a good question it's you mean if
you write a script and you keep trying to get
it made and getting it made and it's not working
yeah I don't know it depends on who you're talking
to if you you don't have any contacts and you're
slowly building up who and getting people to
read it it could take a process of years but
if you had a project that you gave to your agent
your manager and you had some producers read and
everybody was kind of not really jiving with it
I would say put it away and write something out
so it kind of depends on where you're at it's
if you've got a great script but you don't have
access to get the proper people to read it for
a couple years it's going to take a couple years
so your instinct should tell you everything though
people are really responding the right people if
you can get some right people to really read it if
you do one of those coverage things or something
and they give you 50 pages of coverage maybe
you're in trouble but so so that's I don't really
know the answer to that but I think you just have
to use your instinct on what's working what's not
sometimes you write a script and it's not good
enough how do again just instinct it's I've worked
on things where it feels great but it doesn't
feel amazing it's it feels it's almost there
or maybe the first 60 pages are seem really
amazing but the the third act doesn't work
so you just have to know I wrote a high script
recently I was working on I got inspired and
quickly wrote this high school I think the
first 60 pages are great but the the third
act is horrible which usually not something that
happens it's not horrible but it doesn't keep up
with the rest of the film and I'm not getting any
inspiration to to come up with the third act so
I just put it away for now maybe I'll revisit in
six months or three months or two years from now
but you just kind of have to know when
things are working and when they're not
are you banging your head against the wall that's
not good if there's something that you feel is
you can't crack the nut all the way through
or figure it out you should maybe think about
something or put it down for a while sometimes you
can put something down and come back to it there's
a lot of people I know a lot of directors I know
who worked on things for years they put things
away and they come back to them and they'll be
hey wow this is pretty cool but they have a fresh
perspective on it all was there a project that
taught you how important your instinct was maybe
you didn't pay attention to it before when it came
to writing yeah I think it happened I think the
movie Rage that we did the screenplay was called
Tokarev originally I love this movie this British
film called The Long Good Friday which has Bob
Hoskins in it it's from the early 80s and I was I
want to do something that and I kept thinking and
then I mentioned to a few people and they didn't
know the movie or they just were yeah whatever
and I was no this could make a really cool
thing tonally it was that kind of movie the
story's completely different but it kind
of had the same tone and that was when we were
writing a lot of horror things just doing horror
Sean [writing partner Sean Keller] and I were
just doing horror that's all I was working on
and I was no this thriller is a cool thriller and
it's got a lot of things that are going for it and
I wrote half the script in one day I just kept
thinking about it then I sent over Sean he did
some work on and we finished it and it got amazing
response and it was one of those times where I was
I think I need to move from horror into
thriller stuff and this is a really cool idea
and it worked and everybody loved the script and
it got made and did really well for us so because
of that you realized okay I can trust myself yeah
yeah same thing happened with writing a pilot too
for that we sold the ABC it's we never worked in
tv and then one day I was we should write a pilot
we decided to write a pilot and how to find copies
of pilots to even know the structure and I think
we call our manager it's hey can you send us some
pilots and wrote a pilot without ever knowing
anything about pilots and there was a bidding war
between ABC and NBC for when we sold it didn't get
made but it was another one of those times where
it's I don't know never worked on tv but it feels
maybe we should do some tv so yeah just follow
a lot of instinct stuff works don't know why.
Question
For The Viewers:
How do a screenplay isn't good enough?